are you doing with your speed dating
today
hi steve how are you good
it's i can't imagine what you're going
through um so i got a bunch of things
let's just try to
jump in uh uh how did the cardi b cameo
happen
you know one of the great things about
doing fast now versus when we first
started
is that i think when we first started
you know we can't even get calls
returned and now we get incoming calls
so
um whenever you can come and call uh we
we try to find a good fit so it was her
idea to do move
i got i got a call like i think or
actually i think in this case uh vin got
a call
and uh and we we talked about it and
next thing you know
i was seeing her and she was coming in
and she just
she's one of the most amazing people by
the way like she came in
she looked at the script memorized it
like on the fly i
unbelievable uh that's awesome
um i you you've done um
some crazy set pieces in these movies
is there one that you're like like just
really extremely proud of like the one
that
if no one had seen any of these set
pieces the one you want people to see
i don't know i i i always take pride in
in everything and i learn from it and go
on but um i know they they all
present something unique you know i i
think in this film
uh the the opening race to me you know
it was the first thing that i kind of
worked on and i i i i just love
i love the kind of going back to basics
feel of that and trying to stay very
disciplined
uh making sure that uh even though we
can have we can do anything we want
um let's really stay true to to you know
the the moment
and so um i don't know i mean i think
the
the vault was great the bus flip uh a
lot of the
tokyo drift um uh races and chases
um uh comes up for me um
and even flip cars like i i when i when
i had the idea
we were told uh there's no way you can
flip a car because
it's and and we tried it and that first
take it actually flipped the car so like
things like that happy accidents
sometimes you know
those are the things that jump up for me
uh all of us at collider
are huge fans of this franchise so i ask
this
for all of us uh where are you at in the
development
of the next movie because all of us
obviously are excited
even though this is about to come out i
have to ask you yeah no it's interesting
because
uh when i came back you know it was
really for this idea of jacob
uh for for for exploring this theme of
family but through blood
and basically because i felt like if to
do that we we we now get the
the right to to kind of go back and and
really explore the
and cement the mythology from the origin
story you know and
and i think from it i realized you know
we're 20 years in
uh let's really kind of embrace and have
some fun you know with where
we've been and where we are now but what
was
what was really interesting was that
when i came back vin pulled me aside and
said you're not leaving
you know you're you're work we're gonna
we're gonna end this thing
and i thought wow because around 2009
2010
we just started talking you know i
remember it was me and vin and paul and
we would talk about
like the end of this saga and i've
always thought it was something that we
talked about and we were never
ever going to actually you know uh bring
it to life
and so in many ways it felt right it
felt
very organic um and so as i'm here
speaking with you
it it really has already been formed
through time you know there's there's
still a lot of kind of logistics and a
lot of things to
to work on of course you know but i i
think the conversation
we now have for almost a decade
i i gotta go but do you see yourself
filming fast 10 this year or is it next
year
uh not not not this year i mean i think
right now i can't even get on a plane to
to go scout
so um uh i i will be on that first plane
once i'm
allowed to um but but uh i i think
definitely production next year
got it thank you so much and congrats on
the movie hope it's a huge hit
thank you so much have a great day